cbs news meteorologist and climate
specialist jeff baradelli joins us now
for a look at the weekend
weather and jeff i gather for a lot of
folks it's not ideal
no not here in new jersey i'm on the
boardwalk here in seaside heights i have
many a fun memory in my childhood of
being here each and every summer but
unfortunately the memories
will not be fun weather-wise at least
for the next couple of days it's gonna
be rainy
it's gonna be chilly and it's gonna be
windy so let's start out what's going on
right now across the country and we have
some storms in texas could cause some
flight delays today in places like
dallas
and would you believe to the north in
wisconsin it is snowing
at the end of may so there's a lot of
cold air still left over you can see it
there on the radar
this storm is going to slowly move to
the east and then put
the brakes on and we'll see waves of
rain maybe two to four inches of rain in
places like
new jersey and new york city look at
those temperatures
record low maximum temperatures with
highs only
in the 50s on saturday and really even
into sunday the pick day
for memorial day weekend is going to be
monday that's when we'll finally see
some improvement
and across the west you know this is not
good it's really dry one of the worst
droughts in modern history
soil moisture is the driest it's been in
about 125 years
and now we have a heat wave on top of
that with high temperatures in the
valleys of california
105 to 110 on sunday
and monday so please be very careful if
you're out barbecuing because the ground
is dry
and flammable gail chef you're breaking
a lot of hearts can you explain why it's
90 degrees on wednesday and sunny
and now we come to the weekend and it's
going to be cold and cloudy and rainy
thanks a lot jeff beridelli
my my pleasure thank you sir